vous a volé le
scoop scoop way ah oui ça c'est un truc
que vous avez pas digéré julien j'aurai
mon père il annonce enfin il est mon
père a joué le jeu de je pensais que
c'est lui qui à dire je vais être
papilles mais en fait c'est gilles
verdez qui a dit benjamin va être
papilles alors qu'on lui avait dit pas
encore le dire c'est encore un peu tôt
bande de jaloux de les papilles comme ça
c'est oui une fois torride ont quitté
difficilement vérifiables ne va pas bon
bref moi je voulais pas en plus on
l'avait dit ne le fait pas parce que
certains taux
vénère faut le dire mais oui ça m'avait
d'ailleurs je trouve pas ça correct
c'est je trouve qu'on ne peut pas comme
ça se permettre de dire des choses même
si ça doit être mon père qui est un
petit peu tête en l'air qui a dû le dire
ça fait le truc j'ai commencé je trouve
ça pas bien et c'est pas trop vis-à-vis
de moi parce que moi fondamentalement je
m'en fous et c'est par rapport à pas non
c'est plutôt vis-à-vis des parents de
karak
que ça va bien le plus vrai souci
c'est pas méchant monsieur
jean dénommé non mais à défaut de tenir
tes femmes qui atterrissent au moins
là
[Applaudissements]
zagré 6 puis ils ont été changées sur
trois était gentil
j'ai mis en valeur la famille en
annonçant gentiment la nouvelle
qui va annoncer lundi la nouvelle quand
va tout va quitter tu vois là tu les
prix d'annoncé n'était pas en cours
jamar à dire la vérité mais je suis un
homme honnête c'est toujours la vérité
il l'a fait avec mon conte 103
avait donc c'est de ma faute
développement vise à un papa est
toujours en tête en l'air
a été fier de l'annoncé bien sûr et
c'est à lahonce et or est comme
d'habitude
m toi et que tu sois au long de la bande
et quelques mots l'os comme cabot ça
voilà qui fait beaucoup tué par denis
même pas
dans lucky luke
un
petit buzz se voit jamais sans raison
mais ça va toi c'est toi qui est bizarre
pour moi tu as fait ça ces raisons et
surtout
une belle annonce familial tu laisse à
croire à une guerre chroniqueurs
on attend rajoute encore maintenant mais
se faisait plaisir de donner un scoop
âgées il a pris valable à ses basques
c'est intense à miliana d'aucun type et
oui ça va on a une info people
intéressant de my way il va donner un
scoop un lieu où l'on tombe bien
castaldi tchèque va dire à gbagbo s'est
fait plaisir
[Musique]